all of us have um uh kind of an identity  for ourselves a way of defining  ourselves  and human beings don't usually stray  from that so if you consider yourself to  be a conservative person or a shy person  i know the way you move to some extent i  know the facial expressions the gestures  the way you use your body and it's all  consistent with the fact that human  beings  our strongest drive  is the need to stay consistent with how  we define ourselves if your  self-definition is uh i'm a situation  where i'm kind of what was the word he  used shy shy  then you're going to find a way to get  to a place where you kind of cower back  right the fastest thing you could do to  change your experience would be to  create a new little thing a simple thing  like erase then you go i'm shy go erase  that's a bs story a bs meaning uh belief  system  now that that's just a story and if you  tell yourself a story long enough you  start to believe it once you believe it  you act like